in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Tyler
and Stephanie are with us hey how are ya
okay
welcome welcome good to have you guys
thanks for hanging out with us today so
you traveled from where were you from
Oklahoma City small town called Jones on
the east part of Oklahoma City very cool
love it and here to do your debt-free
scream we are and how much have you paid
off one hundred and twelve thousand I
love it excellent how long did that take
19 months good very good and range of
income during that time started off at
125 mm-hmm and it grew to 160 over the
course of a bunch of hard work and extra
jobs I was gonna ask how you jump that
much an extra 45,000 or 35,000 dollars
that's pretty quick man what do you guys
do for a living I'm a retail pharmacist
mm-hmm I'm a stay-at-home mom very cool
so what'd you do pick up some like some
hospital work as a pharmacist 2 or and
some extra work at that pharmacy and
well that and took on two extra Dave
jobs so to speak
oh okay what kind of Dave jobs to Jeff I
did consulting for an Indian health
services clinic good and then I also did
a on call weekend gigs with hospital
yeah that's what I was thinking okay
good because those pay pretty good but
they're a pain in the butt yeah exactly
yeah okay cool a lot of pharmacists for
mercy folks do that over the years to
get out of debt that's how I knew that
we get discount Stephanie because she
did substitute teaching oh and she
started kind of her own house cleaning
service okay she didn't mention that she
just said stay-at-home mom named
pergolas I did house cleaning I did
substitute teaching pretty much anything
I can do while my kids were in school to
earn extra people how much what kind of
debt was the hundred and twelve well a
hundred and eight was my student loan
from 2005 been hanging out a while they
have time to give old Sallie Mae her
eviction notice and so we were just
making the regular payments like you're
supposed to yeah paid off over the
thirty-year payment period yeah right
and it actually was working
counterproductive because our loan had
grown to one hundred and twelve Wow
since 2005 just with the interest it
altered loan yeah there's the whole
thing no other debt but the student loan
in your house you still got it still got
our house oh god yeah so what happened
19 months ago that this switch flipped
it what caused this it started back in
probably 2009 yeah we were going to a
Life Church Rochelle yeah we were in a
life group and they were gonna do the
FPU series and she told me she said I I
think we need to do this and i suppo
we're unique they teach arrogance in
medical school so we kind of thought it
was so large that it was like having two
mortgages yeah he just bumped it back
yeah it makes it different baby step you
know seven yeah so we started you know a
friend of ours loaned us their workbook
and we kind of went through the workbook
and it taught us you taught us how to do
the budget I decide to save great and so
what we were doing is saving all his
money and paying cash for other things
that we thought we needed hmm so and if
you add up what we saved and spent over
that period of time since 2009 is about
$100,000 mmm okay enough yeah exactly
and so we called in I started listening
to the show and I called in and about
2011-2012 my lunch period and we were at
the point where we were getting
frustrated thought we were gonna have to
maybe sell the house because we've got a
high house payment and I said I'm just
gonna call him see what he says and you
called me out on it you threw me under
the money and I was mad and I felt
insulted a good three months I didn't
listen but all the meantime we were
still doing the the envelopes and the
budgeting she's the nerd I'm the free
spirit and she's got this spreadsheet
that if she ever dies I'm gonna have to
have an interpreter to show me how to
work there's in the will
encryption is in the will so she I said
you know I think I think we really need
maybe check in with him again and see
what he says and I said I'm not calling
again you call you're actually very
helpful and told us some good advice and
that kind of got us started yeah and so
from that point you know it kind of lit
a fire you had told her you said no no
no for this balance making the income
you should have it done in three years
and so I heard that and I said well if
he says three I'm gonna say two
Oh and so that was the target and I said
two years we got to get it done and so
then that was in September of 2014 and
it took a little while I had an
opportunity a friend presented me with a
Indian clinic and said hey I got some
extra jobs if you need some extra income
and I said sure so it takes a while to
get on with the federal government get
the clearance of whatnot and so all that
kicked in in January and in the meantime
I'd applied at the hospital and said hey
if you you need any extra work and they
said well we don't have an opportunity
for you now well they called me back two
months later and said we'll take we'll
take the job you know we'll take what
you can offer yeah and so I just laid
everybody my schedule out and said hey
here it is take what you can get and so
I didn't have a day off Wow it was you
went crazy for 19 it's gone just like
that right yeah man and and the you know
the aggravating thing is is that we
should tell every pharmacy student that
story on the day they graduate if
they're sitting cuz most of them are
looking at around 100 100 and a half if
they took out student loans right
they're looking at that and most of them
make a hundred and a quarter right and
and they can do just what you did and
they don't have to wait ten years you
know but nobody tells me buy this stuff
hmm so you guys are fun this when you
start pharmacy school they they say
don't worry about the loans because your
first year you'll make more than your
loan value yeah and so they just brush
it under the rug you know four years
later you graduate how much ya really
live with this thing
yeah Sallie Mae's got her own freaking
bedroom yeah so I got your brothers in
Craig Groeschel smiling right now cuz he
listens most days so right now he's just
going
thumbs up for you guys I'm proud of you
too your hero's very very well done so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is well you've got
to do the budget but
you gotta agree with one another and a
good support network mm-hmm and a lot of
Prayer now you guys were doing the
budget before though yeah and that
didn't do it what did it was when you
decided right yeah and then you worked
like animal you commit to it and we were
moving when you decided right we were
still doing retirement we stopped
retirement yes we stopped all that and
then we started doing them exactly like
you've got it laid out yeah we cashed in
the money we had in savings went down to
the thousand and we worked it just like
your plan says you guys awesome it's
amazing you know you are heroes I'm so
proud of you
very very well done thank you very well
done we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's book a signed copy retire
inspired a number one national
bestseller that's your next step now yes
as you're making all this money you
don't have any payments but a house
payment now let's get the house paid off
and let's build wealth and live and give
like no one else you guys are on track
man I'm proud of your way to go it was a
LP on Friday all right okay guys count
it down a hundred and twelve thousand
dollars paid off in nineteen months
making 125 to 160 let's hear your debt
free scream came in and Kindle this is
for you three three two
well done you guys that's how it works
you know there's a lot of stuff I can't
help you with if you have a brain tumor
I can't do surgery if you need someone
to work on your car I can't help you if
you need someone to do dot dot dot I
can't help you but we have this process
of handling money God's ways figured out
in a system that over 10 million people
have used to become debt-free and I
gotta tell you it for your sake I'm okay
I'm okay
my personal identity is not tied up in
whether you agree with me or not if you
don't agree with me about this stuff
you're what's known as we're all the
evidence is in you're wrong so why would
you say something stupid like I'm gonna
sorta do Dave Ramsey stuff either do it
or don't but when you decide that's when
you change your life you've got to
decide that we got this figured out do
it exactly the way we're talking about
try it what have you got to lose this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar in the company
you